what's actually the most upsetting is
this
i find it extremely hypocritical and of
all the things in the world my pet
peeves the things that annoy me most are
hypocrites i find it extremely
hypocritical that the system itself
pretends it gives issues about men's
mental health it will sit there and
pretend it cares about all the men out
there who are depressed struggling sad
but when i come along and tell them the
only way i've ever found personally to
be happy and contented because i can
only talk my personal story is to become
a man of status to become successful to
go through pain to use my trauma to use
the bad things that happened to me to
galvanize myself against attacks from
the matrix as i've just proven i can
easily weather
when i talk about men's mental health
they delete me i thought you gave it
about men's mental health i'm the most
popular man on the planet and ninety
percent of my content is likely about
women it's motivational and
anti-depressive and you're gonna sit
here and delete me saying i'm bad for
women what about men i thought you gave
all of a sudden you don't give a [ __ ]
anymore right just delete him who cares